in this video we will understand the
continuous division method to find the
hcf of two numbers
say we want to find the hcf of 24 and
36. this method is generally used for
large numbers
but first let's try it out with smaller
ones
this video is slightly lengthy and i
would need you to focus really hard for
the next few minutes
as the name says we have to use division
in the first step we divide the greater
number by the smaller number
here
36 is the greater number
so we divide 36 by 24
we are generally used to writing the
quotient on top
but in this method we will write it here
24 times 1 is 24
and 36 minus 24 is 12.
but wait we're not done yet
the name says continuous division
this was just the first part
we got the quotient as one and the first
remainder as 12.
we call this the first remainder as we
get many remainders in this method
in the second step we divide the smaller
number by the first remainder the
smaller number is 24
so we write 24 here
we are dividing the smaller number by
the first remainder
12 times 2 is 24
and 24 minus 24
is zero
we continue this till we get the
remainder as zero
and guess what we already have the hcf
the final divisor becomes the hcf
so here the hcf will be 12.
the hcf of 24 and 36 is 12.
we divide continuously till we get the
remainder as zero
this part was our first division and
this was our first remainder
since it wasn't zero we performed the
second division in which the smaller
number became the dividend and we
continued this till we got a zero
but wait
what if we wouldn't have got a zero here
what would be the next dividend
let's look at another example to
understand that
we try to find the hcf of 1044
and 1512.
in the first step we divide the larger
number by the smaller number
that is we divide one thousand five
hundred and twelve by one thousand and
forty four
one thousand forty four times one is one
thousand forty four
one is the largest quotient possible
here since one thousand forty four times
two is two thousand eighty eight which
is greater than one thousand five
hundred and twelve
and this minus this
is four hundred and sixty eight
this becomes our first remainder
since it's not zero we continue with our
division
the smaller number becomes the next
dividend and the first remainder becomes
the divisor
so we write
1044 here
and then we write
468 times 2 equals
and this minus this equals 108.
now we completed the second stage and
the remainder is not zero
so how do we continue further
well it's easy the first remainder
becomes the dividend and the second
remainder becomes the divisor
we can write the next step as r1 divided
by r2
the first remainder is
so we write it here
this is r1 divided by r2
this is the third division we are
performing for this example
108 times 4 equals
432 and 468
minus 432
equals 36.
the remainder is still not zero
the next step is simple
it will be r2 divided by r3
this is the second remainder and this is
the third remainder
hence we write the second remainder
which is 108 here
we're dividing r2
by r3
36 times 3 is 108
and finally we get the remainder as zero
that's where we stop
and the final divisor becomes the hcf
hence the hcf of 1044
and
1512 is 36.
there is another way in which you can
look at it
look at the first example
if the remainder is not 0 the divisor
becomes the next dividend
it's the same thing in the second
example where we performed 4 division
processes
and 4.
the first remainder was non-zero
became the next dividend
then
468 became the next dividend since r2
was not zero
and then 108 became the next dividend
and we stopped since the remainder
became zero
and for every division process the
remainder is the divisor
and remember once you get the remainder
as zero
the final divisor becomes the hcf
you